hey guys its feet peppers and I'm going
to talk about the new game farm hero
super saga I had a question about level
17 on my page today so I'm going to go
ahead and play it and talk about moving
around fidget the squirrel here it's
telling us that if we match next to the
squirrel it'll power it up and that when
the counter hits zero it'll trigger or
special move that could be a little bit
confusing because the special move for
the squirrel is that it'll use its tail
to clear a larger area but it won't get
the won't get the a corner unless it's
right next to it so what we need to do
first is we need to move these two
things out of their little notches there
and move them closer together so we're
going to go ahead and do that it's a
windy level so you can see that the
direction that we move is the way that
the the pieces move so you see you match
left you swipe left and you get things
moving to the left so what we want to do
is we want to make a match above where
the squirrel is that's moving towards
the top of the board like this green
right here will work you see we he moves
up one space alright same thing here
except for we don't have a match right
now that I'll move him so we'll go ahead
we want to move this to the left or this
down and like I said right now we don't
have a match that's set up so we'll just
make some other matches collect some of
our collections and get it set up
so here if we move this Apple or this
pair to the left it's going to move the
squirrel to the last see that
and again we don't have one so we're
going to set it up and we had that
happen in a cascade which is always good
so now we can move this to the right or
down and we can move this to the left or
up and this will move it up so we'll go
ahead and move it up
move them up again
so this if we move this to the right
it's going to move the Acorn all the way
over here so that would be a good thing
now we can move squirrel to the left and
you can see his little counter there
it's at 16 so he's close enough now that
if we could see how his tail went out
further and we made us a thing it
collected it for us so now all we have
to do is collect a couple more bananas
and we'll complete the level so it's
something that definitely takes some
chant some some getting used to when you
first play it it is a cool feature once
you get the hang of it but you know you
just have to mess around and use think
about the swipe the direction you're
swiping the actual crop see if it's in
line with whatever you're trying to move
whether it's the Acorn or the squirrel
or later the little goat they're going
to move in that direction so i hope this
video helps please like it if you found
it helpful make sure to subscribe to my
channel and if you need help with
something check out my facebook farm
here super saga tips page and leave a
comment there and i'll try to help you
out as soon as they can thanks